Thank you so much.
It's fantastic to be here, and I also just
really want to thank Trent and Whitney, and
all the organisers who helped me out this
morning so that I can be here on this stage,
and it's an excitement to get to close out
CSSconf, because the last time I was here
on the stage, I was giving a talk which was
really a call to action.
In some ways, I see this talk as perhaps a
part 2 of that, or, if you haven't seen it,
answering some of the questions that I proposed
at the end.
I'm going to talk about design systems but
not in the normal sense we're used to hearing
about design systems, I want to talk about
it through the lens of facilitation.
This is marrying two things that I love: one,
design systems, and the second thing I've
come to fall in love with in the last couple
of years is this topic of facilitation.
What I hope to do for you today is introduce
facilitation and to show you how it is actually
an incredible and really powerful tool, and
how our design systems really, although we
build them to establish consistency across
our products, are actually acting as facilitators
within our organisations.
And how this is super instrumental in , and
I see is it one of the first key steps in
helping to transform our educational structures,
and helping us build resilient teams as well
as products.
This is a neat facilitation tool.
You can enter the code CSS EU, and you can
leave questions and upvote other people's
questions.
If I have enough time at the end, I will take
a look at them.
If we don't get a look to them, this is a
great starting point to find me afterwards.
Discuss and debate, tell me what you liked
and didn't like.
That's what we are hear for at this conference,
and that's one of the greatest reasons I believe
to gather.
As I started working on this talk, I came
across this talk.
This is how I had to start this because this
is getting at the core of my trajectory in
my life and how I got to come to this point
of interest.
This is really true for me: the older I get,
or the longer I've been working in tech, the
more every problem seems to be a matter of
getting humans to work together effectively,
and it is actually not about the tech itself.
So I started out at the beginning coding,
heads down, member of a team, and through
my almost 12 years, I got to the point where
I was building teams, and thinking about the
other people on my team.
And to the only thinking about the people
on my team, but thinking about how we interacted
with other parts of the organisation.
And this really drove home to me, because
this is exactly what I would encounter.
It didn't matter how great my codebase was,
at the end of the day, if the members of the
team, if we couldn't communicate effectively,
then the process wasn't great and our products
weren't great at the end.
So this issue is actually what drove me to
start to focus on organisations and structures,
and I know this is a conference about CSS,
but, we work together as people, and we work
under organisations, and really, when I think
about organisations, I view them as a place
which just interactions with human beings.
This became the question that I've been driven
by for the last year and a half: how do we
design our organisational structures for participation?
To actually allow for participation to happen?
And beyond that, how do we ensure that we
have a balance of the bottom up with the top
down?
And we don't end up with too much of the other?
And in comes to how we are going to work in
our organisations.
Because, if we don't, our products aren't
going to be as great.
And so, while I'm still writing CSS I assure
you - and JavaScript - I'm also doing a lot
of other things.
I'm learning a lot about ethnography and research,
and, to answer this question, I want to share
a story with you, and this is a story that,
for me, really married my call twin-tracks
to action on my last talk which was really
let's think about the human layer of what
we are doing, right?
Let's day about the collaboration and what
our tools are enabling.
So finning out about what happened in Taiwan
and the history of Taiwan became this really
big revelation for me.
If you don't mind, I'm going to tell you a
little bit about Taiwan.
In 2014, there was an occupation in Taiwan,
called the Sun Flower Movement.
The.
The government of tie would be tried to pass
a loafed-door deal with China.
There was a great media org called watch-out
starting to live broadcast the events of the
proceeding.
When they found out, this news got on the
internet, and, in less than five minutes,
students and citizens of Taiwan, decided to
occupy their parliament.
This is like the US occupying the White House
in Europe, occupying just the biggest seat
of government that you could find.
And they barricaded it and sets themselves
up there, and they were there for over a month.
It wasn't mayhem, it wasn't as if they weren't
accomplishing anything.
They actually were leading a non-violent occupation,
and one of the most most interesting things
is they showed the government how they wanted
the government to respond.
They set up live streaming infrastructure,
they held debates and discussions in the streets,
and this is powered by their civic [sound
distort ed].
And it did lead to change.
The government was so embarrassed by what
happened, that they invited one of the members
from the civic community to enter government.
[Sound distorted].
This is to me the ultimate marriage of the
bottom-up power with the topdown, or the bottom-up
with the top-down power.
They are using this legislation to do things,
for example, to regulate what to do about
Uber, instead of London trying to shut it
down, they took it into suggestion.
They used it to figure out what to do about
air B and N - Airbnb and regulate most net
laws.
I went digging and thought there must be some
amazing piece of technological piece of software
behind this, and there wasn't.
There was a simple facilitation method, called
the focus conversation method - objective,
reflective, interpretative, and decisional.
I've named this to something simple: it starts
with finding facts.
We need to be clear about what those facts
are.
Along with the facts, it is okay, we need
to sort out the feelings.
What do people feel about in stuff?
Then, I think this is a wonderful framework
to consider what you're design systems are
doing and how to go about building them in
a way that doesn't lead to issues of rejection,
even though I will show you how that is a
part of it.
So if we think about our design systems and
we start gathering our facts, the first thing
we want to do is find out what currently exists?
Who are the stakeholders?
What is out there in our organisations that
we can build off of?
Then need to find the feelings.
This is a really important one.
And one where you're probably going to get
a lot of emotions, but if you working on the
design system are approaching this as an idea
of I am facilitating, I'm listening, then
you can kind of step back.
We shush asking people how we think this should
work.
This is a time to ask people their feelings
about naming or how we should organise stuff.
Let's get the feelings out.
How do people feel about our existing design
system if we had one, or existing attempt
to make one.
What worked?
What, did not?
Once we get to this, we can generate ideas.
What is this tooling going to be?
How is it going to work?
How will the team begin to interact with it?
Then we can document our decisions, and we
should document our decisions, and they should
point back to the whole process so people
can see why we made the choices that we made.
And we should be transparent.
So at the end of the day, facilitation is
doing is really making an action or process
easier.
Our design systems do this, right?
They make coding easier.
You don't have to repeat the same code.
Ideally, if they are well documented, they
help you find answers, the questions that
you may have, so you don't have to implement
it.
And so, a facilitator is the person that is
in charge of sort of designing this process,
and they think a lot about what things can
they do all along the way to make the action
or the whole journey much easier?
We're trying to make design easier, coherent,
less opaque.
Our design practices that we are really using
are designed to help make our processes a
lot easier, and to help us arrive at this
point of shared understanding.
Stephanie Hughes has a great video called
Architecting Interaction.
She's an architect but takes things from a
systems point of view, and she says facilitating
is about creating contexts that are incomplete,
right?
They're not quite finished.
Think about our design systems.
They are never quite finished.
That's okay.
Also, they're impermanent, which means they're
going to change.
That's also okay.
Lastly, they're imperfect.
And I don't know about you, but every design
system that I've built is pretty imperfect,
although while it gets the job done.
The way I like to think about this is each
stage of our design system is facilitating
a context and it's creating an environment,
and this is the environment where we can get
things done as people, right?
That environment is helping us achieve a sense
of shared understanding for that moment so
that we can move forward and make another
decision.
This is a cyclical thing that we work through
on our design system.
Where we start is not where we will end up.
Constantly, we are thinking about creating
these environments that allow for conversation,
and allow for us to get to a point of shared
understanding to take the next step forward.
So, really, what we are doing is designing
the context for interactions.
I think about our design system this one level
up and we think about help in the place of
our organisations, they're designing those
interactions, the interactions that we have
between people in different departments, right?
This is another great talk by Jess Clark,
and I highly recommend it: evolving your design
system, people, product, and process.
She talks about the different stages that
the linked linked design system - Linked In
design system went through.
She divides her process, communication, collaboration,
co-ordination, and contribution, to her represent
that happens at each stage of a design process
as it matures.
I would like to say if our design systems
are actually facilitators, then these are
the things that we need to be designing for
and accounting for at every stage of the process
from our design system, even though it may
change.
Communication in the early days of a design
system might be informal and loose and tapping
someone on the shoulder, and the collaboration
as well might not be super defined, and your
contribution to allow other people to contribute
to your design system might look more like
send me an email when you want something.
But as this evolves, you begin to think about
ways that you can be more communicative with
other people in the organisation, that you
can increase collaboration, that you can mitigate
and design for better co-ordination, and that
you can have better contribution.
Maybe your dream state is getting this to
a pull request.
But I want to urge us to think about how we
are designing our systems to account for these
processes at all levels, and not view it as
an evolution that happens as we get better
and better, we have more better ways of contribution.
It's more as our contacts and needs change,
we evolve our process.
Really, our design systems are facilitating
multi-stakeholder discussions and needs.
And this becomes really, really challenging
in our current organisations because most
of our organisational structures aren't set
up to make this easy.
Which is why I suddenly realised how important
a design system is, and what it really means
when an organisation says, "We're undertaking
a design system."
I would like to start the section by thinking
about this quote.
There's this misconception of the independent
existence, right?
There is no such mode of existence.
Every entity is to be understood in terms
of the way it's interwoven with the rest of
the universe.
When I think about this in the context of
our organisations, I'm thinking about this
issue where we often have these org charts,
in command-and-control pattern, even though
the universe doesn't work that way.
The universe is like this more collaborative,
decentralised network.
Furthermore, what is challenging is our design
systems are about the collaborative network,
and we are trying to get to that while we
are existing in this extremely centralised
model.
So perhaps, to me, one of the most powerful
things that our design systems do when introduced
into an organisation, is they become one of
the first manifestations of a team that is
trying to work across all of these silos.
Face it, that is really hard.
Because our structures aren't set up for that.
So you're doing an amazing job to keep pushing
this through.
These are two articles that came out a couple
of years ago, one is by Nathan Curtis, and
another is a response by Gina, and Nathan
is looking at various models how to scale
a design system.
He talks about three.
He says there is this solitary Over Lord model,
that there is one person that makes the design
system, he's super excited and focused on
his team's needs - I was that person for a
while.
It's easy to be that to learn person if you
punish this forward.
There's a centralised pattern which is a single
central design them that produces and supports
the system and everyone else is using it;
and there is a concept of a federal pattern
where multiple members of the team decide
on the system together.
While it's always best to aim for a cross-functional
team where we are really pulling the people
that we need from different departments to
make our design testimonies, I think if we
take this idea of a design system as a facilitator,
it is also okay happens to be if you're that
solitary person working on your design system.
What that means is that you need to design
all of your processes to be incredibly open,
and to go out into the organisation and to
find out what the people actually need, so
you're going to be not only the developer
of the design system but a UX reserver team
of one, which is really hard, but that is
a way to get started, and I believe by doing
that, you won't end up with a design system
that fees like an over-Lord because the process
by which you designed it was more of a facilitatory
process.
Because our organisational systems aren't
set up for design systems and a lot of battle
of the design system is to get that buy-in
so you can make your cross-functional team,
resistance and chaos are always going to be
a part of the process.
We just must embrace it now.
All right?
If we can embrace this, we can also get out
of it, and see how we can help facilitate
the processes to make this more manageable.
So here are two, I'm going to share two design
models.
This is the Double Diamond design model which
states as you start with a problem, you will
have divergent thinking, and then eventually
going to define it and converge.
Then of you you're going to have an answer,
and, again was as you generate ideas, you
get divergent thinking, and, as you start
to test them, you're going to converge.
I view this as something to accept, right?
This might feel really chaotic to people that
why do we have so much divergent thinking
again?
Can't we just all agree?
It's okay.
It's totally part of the process.
I think that, if we can make this clear too
as facilitators, as people here to guide members
of our orgs through this, it helps them understand
that there will be a solution at the end.
The other model I recently came into and wanted
to share because it really helped me just
become Zen with chaos and resistance in organisations
is this change model.
This comes from family therapy.
In our organisations, we've got this status
quo, and we have to introduce we've got to
change.
This foreign element comes into play.
In this case, our foreign element is the design
system, and the design system team.
As soon as any foreign element is introduced
into the existing system, it's a period of
chaos.
It's absolute chaos.
People become emotional, they have their own
feelings, they don't want to use it, they
say it was better the way it was before, you're
constantly fighting, until suddenly this thing
starts to take root, and you can see this
transformation into an idea, and eventually,
we get, it becomes part of our practice, and
we integrate it, and then we end up at a new
level.
We're at this new level until the next northern
element enters, and we begin this again.
So, ask we are building design systems, if
we can really think about ways to facilitate
that way through chaos, and this is part of
why taking on these facilitation models by
talking to people and not being in our solitary
teams, by finding out how they're feeling
about stuff, really helps us make our way
through the change model.
So, really, what we should be focusing on
is the outcomes in our design systems, and
not the outputs.
Because the outcomes are actually what drive
impact.
And the outputs and the design system I like
to think about as the components, right?
And so you might want to have a design system
that has tons of outputs.
You've covered all the possible component
patterns, you did it, everything is in the
system, hurrah.
But that's not going to be great.
Because, in taking that approach, in order
to do that, you might find yourself trampling
over people.
So, if we focus more on what we are hoping
these things will do in our organisation,
such as facilitate conversation, be that spark
of interaction, I think that we can design,
it will help us design these better systems.
And is to, it is really about building as
much as we need when we need it.
What I want to say here is please don't be
embarrassed about your design systems if your
design system is a PDF, or if your design
system is a sketch file, or if your design
system has red line marks on it.
Please don't be embarrassed if your design
system isn't in a fancy repo and has all these
amazing components that you can import.
You were build what you needed for that moment
in time, right?
You were trying to focus on that outcome.
Starting with a PDF might get you to a point
where you designed a context where at least
you can have discussions, and that's the what
matters.
In the next stage, you can think about evolving
it to meet the needs of your team.
So really, again, I cannot stress, focus on
those outcomes, really assess your teams,
and determine what it is that you need.
A lot times within I really think that it
is about communication and talking, and breaking
down those silos and the human-to-human interactions.
Really, when we think about designing sustainably
and designing sustainable systems, it is about
facilitating a process which is what we are
doing with our design systems.
We're empowering that system to deal with
change.
This is what makes it proactive and more resilient,
and able to anticipate the futures of what
will come.
In another model, it's called the viable system
model, he talks about this concept of autopoeisis,
which is the idea that a system has everything
inside of it to better itself and to get better
- in our body, this is the mitochondria.
If our design systems are facilitators, I
like to think we designed this context, and
we have a collection of processes that we
can constantly use, and employ to help our
design systems grow.
So, for me, it goes back to that focus conversation
method and remembering to listen, and also
remembering that we are doing is looking to
create these incomplete, these impermanent,
and these imperfect structures because that
is setting up the first environment and the
first context for our discussions.
And so lastly, I want to leave you with a
quote from one of my favourite heroes, this
is Audrey Tang, currently the digital minister
in Taiwan and rub the V Taiwan process.
She says: deliberation, listening to each
other deeply, thinking and living and making
something we can all live with is magical.
This is really the beauty behind our design
systems and what we are getting at.
We are deliberating, exchanging ideas, and
trying to arrive at a final product - that
design system.
But let's not get so focused in the design
system, and let's rather that process in and
of itself is actually to me one of the most
magical parts about creating these.
Thank you so much.
[Applause]